fabrice di vizio avocat de didier raoul
bonsoir fabrice di vizio merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france
votre client professeur out et donc
visés on l'a entendu par des plaintes
concernant certains de ses propos
polémiques et pour charlatanisme pour
ses positions sur l'idh roxy chloroquine
comment un scientifique tout même
reconnu devient-il soudain un charlatan
c'est pas parce que l'on ne dit que
c'est vrai c'est parce que vendredi que
ça charlatans que c'est vrai ça parce
que l'ordre dit qu'effectivement il fait
beau qui fera beau c'est à dire que si
vous voulez le propos de l'ordre de
langage que l'ordre il est plus que
soutenir ce qu'il veut c'est lui que ça
concerne donc fait l'écho ce raout comme
je l'avais déjà dit parfaitement
tranquille
et depuis quand est ce que pour exercer
depuis quand est ce que pour être
reconnu on a besoin de l'ordre national
des médecins ça se saurait c'est tout de
même symbolique
on imagine voilà que c'est fâcheux pour
un médecin de ne pas être reconnu et
c'est un euphémisme par ses pairs il ya
quand même des procédures disciplinaires
comment réagit votre client alors madame
l'ordre national des médecins c'est pas
les pères il ne pas être reconnu par
land à celle des médecins c'est un
honneur
la même chose reconnu par ses pairs qui
dira ou de l'est maintenant l'ordre
national des médecins envie de perdre
son temps et l'argent des médecins
l'argent issu des cotisations ordinales
des médecins à poursuivre didier rahout
qui lui même était poursuivi déjà par
l'ordre départemental
si ça peut lui faire plaisir qu'il ne
fasse mon client comment est-il réagit
il réagi en déposant une plainte pour
harcèlement contre la personne du
directeur personne du président auront
plutôt de l'ordre national des médecins
plainte pénale a été déposée aujourd'hui
en disant bon allemand donner allez vous
voulez effectivement être ridicule
qu'est soyons le jusqu'au bout elle
puisque vous porter le débat sur le
terrain judiciaire alors jusqu'au bout
pourquoi pour harcèlement m division
précisément pas pourquoi parce que en
avril on a un communiqué de presse qui
vise implicitement que ce raout en
juillet on a effectivement un
signalement à l'ordre départemental du
professeur raout
ensuite on demande alors votre partie
mentale de poursuivre le professeur
raout
et maintenant alors qu'il est poursuivi
l'ordre national poursuit hausse il
conserva août et le tout au milieu de
cinq ou six autres praticiens dont on se
demande effectivement quel est le lien
ok d'accord on a compris l'ordre
national des médecins avaient envie de
finir l'année en montrant les muscles et
en disant que lui bat attention là il
fait des choses bien
la vérité elle est simple c'est que pour
faire le professionnel de l'ordre lhc
d'acheter et rien d'autre maintenant
mais comment vous vous analysé cette
démarche du conseil de l'ordre des
médecins c'est une forme de règlements
de comptes parce que le professeur vente
n'a pas toujours été tendre
justement avec certains autres de ses
collègues médecins ne vous y trompez pas
l'ordre national des médecins finalement
n'a rien versé totalement insignifiant
ce que je veux dire c'est que quand
l'ordre national des médecins hier soir
fait un communiqué de presse dans lequel
il vient effectivement expliqué que six
médecins sont poursuivies dont des
médecins controversé et bien quel est le
but finalement de faire peur aux
professeurs de raul est ce que vous
pensez franchement est ce que l'ordre à
la naïveté de penser que connaisseur out
a peur de lui n'a sûrement pas à ça ce
but but c'est de montrer à la population
médicale que même le professeur raout le
très éminent professeur à outre très
médiatique qu'on essaiera août le très
compétent et influent professeur out est
poursuivi et que donc vous dans votre
cabinet médical
attention à ce que vous faites pas ce
que vous pourriez également être
poursuivi c'est la politique de la
terreur mais l'ordre ne connaît que ça
madame moi je fais ce métier depuis 20
ans l'ordre ne faisais que ça il ne
connaît que ça il a été absent de cette
crise n'a rien dit pour salomon n'a rien
dit pour agnès buzyn ne dit rien à rien
n'a manqué de tout de masques de gants
il n'a rien dit tout ce qui l'intéresse
et de l'hydraulique eurokin et la
politique de la terreur
soit alors c'est vrai m division eaux
tout de même que le professeur out était
très écouté
y avait une tribune médiatique très
suivie il n'a pas dit que des vérités
malheureusement pour nous parce que ces
prévisions étaient souvent plus
optimiste que ne l'est la réalité
aujourd'hui concernant l'évolution de
cette maladie est ce qu'ils payent cela
a eu d'une certaine manière voilà ils
avaient une responsabilité face au
public et on lui fait payer sa vie du
coup on va il ya eu des moments où il
disait voilà qu'on sortirait de la
pandémie assez rapidement avec les beaux
temps il y avait quelqu'un qui n'a pas
d'autre part il ya d'ar men et parce que
madame pardonnez-moi mais alors vous est
ce que vous serez en train de
m'expliquer que l'épidémie est encore
présente et qu'on a laissé les gens
repartir chez repartir partir en
vacances pendant l'été qui serait pas en
train de me dire ça quand même
vous seriez pas en train de me dire que
le professeur out avait tort alors qu'
il y avait encore une pandémie qui
sévissait et qu'on a réouvert le pays de
manière absolument colossal en invitant
les gens partir en vacances parce que là
ce serait comme une irresponsabilité
bien c'est un autre jour d'après les
responsables ont noté effectivement
désolé mais là on parle de la
responsabilité du projet amène à madame
la seule responsabilité que je connaisse
moi c'est celle des autorités sanitaires
mois que le comité de raul tadic y
aurait effectivement un déclin de
l'épidémie de manière notoire en été ou
est ce qu'il a eu tort j'en expliqué là
parce que s'il a eu tort c'est quand
même un problème ça veut dire qu'ils
avaient une épidémie et qu'on a laissé
les gens partir en vacances bon d'accord
vous voyez bien que finalement tout ça
ça s'appelle une chasse aux sorcières
tout ça ça n'a pas de sens et de la
communication et tout ça va se finir en
eau de boudin et rien d'autre et l'ordre
sortira cette affaire plus ridiculisé
qu'il y rentrer et croyez-moi ce n'est
pas fini alors cinq autres médecins sont
sont poursuivis pour pas tout à fait les
mêmes raisons le professeur peron lui a
été démis de ses fonctions de l'ap-hp
pour quelle raison ne vous aura pas
échappé que je ne suis pas l'avocat de
péronne mais vous pouvez tout de même c
c est faire de très près propre et oui
madame la différence c'est que moi je ne
m'intéresse pas contrairement langue
nationale des médecins ou d'autres je ne
m'intéresse pas effectivement aux propos
médiatiques des uns aux autres il n'y à
la couverture médiatique
moi je suis juriste et à ce titre ce qui
m'intéresse ce sont les faits
vous avez interrogé l'avocat du
professeur theron le cas effectivement
aura dû n'aura pas manqué de vous
exposer les raisons pour lesquelles son
client était poursuivi moi je l'ignorent
et je ne sais pas ce que professeur
raoul vient faire dans un lot comme un
espèce de package promotionnelle avec le
professeur peron avec d'autres
effectivement qu'il ne connaît même pas
d'ailleurs je ne vois pas très bien ce
qu'il vient faire dans l'histoire et je
vais vous dire un truc l'ordre eux non
plus ne sais pas parce qu'en fait ça n'a
aucun sens cette histoire ma dernière
question que risque le professeur yao
précisément moi vivant rien merci
fabrice di vizio d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france rappelle que
vous êtes l'avocat de guy dire out
mercier vous